i noticed they have no sort of
compunction about stories regarding a
wide variety of housing situations for a
wide variety of politicians
but if you step on plm's toes this thing
gets shut down only certain types of
misinformation are being shut down
by the social media bros the latest
evidence of this is that twitter has now
banned
james o'keefe why what did what did
james o'keefe do well
his project veritas has been releasing
tape of
cnn directors talking about the bias at
cnn
twitter claimed without evidence
according to the daily wire that o'keefe
was quote violating
the twitter rules on platform
manipulation and spam
according to twitter as outlined in our
policy on platform manipulation and spam
you can't mislead others on twitter by
operating fake accounts and you can't
artificially amplify or disrupt
conversations through the use of
multiple accounts
o'keefe immediately said that this is a
lie he called their statement accusing
him of operating fake accounts false he
said i'm suing twitter for defamation
donald trump jr responded to twitter's
latest crackdown by saying in case you
haven't figured out how it works by now
cnn spreads propaganda to elect
democrats and then twitter runs
interference to protect cnn
they're all on the same team you
remember that not all that long ago the
claim
was that james o'keefe's material
couldn't be put online because it was
some sort of hacked material because it
was undercover material the same sort of
nonsense that they tried trotted out
there to explain
why they were suppressing the hunter
biden story in the month leading up to
the election the idea there was this was
hacked material we can't allow hack
material which is weird since you
allowed
tons and tons of hacked material
throughout the trump administration and
tons and tons of leaky material
throughout the trump administration
again the real story with james o'keefe
is that o'keefe got cnn producers and
directors to admit on tape that they
basically biased their media coverage in
order to ask trump
but according to twitter the bad guy
here is james o'keefe obviously
and it's not just the o'keefe story that
is now being suppressed
facebook apparently is now blocking
users from sharing another new york post
story what exactly is this new york post
story well the new york post reported
as we talked about on the show that
patrice concolors was one of the black
lives matter
co-founders has now purchased a new 1.4
million dollar home
in a super white area of california
according to media i the stories about
con colors a 37 year old self-described
marxist who spent 3.4 million dollars on
homes last year and another 1.4 million
in march
began in the post on april 10th with the
first one titled marxist blm leader buys
1.4 million
home in ritzy la enclave the daily mail
picked it up black enterprise did so two
days later
with a call from new york city blm chief
hawk news i'm calling for an
investigation into where exactly this
money was coming from
when exactly did the media decide to
crack down on this as soon as jason
whitlock
started sharing the story twitter
decided to suspend whitlock for tweeting
out the story
facebook is now banning you from sharing
the new york post story in the first
place in the same way that they banned
you from sharing the hunter biden story
which is insane here is facebook's
explanation for why
they actually blocked the story quote
the article shared multiple details
which could identify the residents of
one of blm founders in violation or
privacy rights as for our community
standards we do not allow people to post
information
or personal or confidential information
about yourself or of others
we remove content that shares offers or
solicits personally identifiable
information or other private information
that could lead to physical or financial
harm
including financial residential and
medical information as well as private
information obtained from illegal
sources
we also provide ways we also provide
people ways to report imagery they
believe to be in violation of their
privacy rights okay so
all they did in this original story was
they shared a picture
of the house they didn't give the exact
location
this sort of reporting is done literally
all the time all the time in fact right
now
online you can find pictures of the
house of the minneapolis officer who's
just brought up on manslaughter charges
you can find pictures on real estate
sites of the house that i just sold in
california it is not difficult to find
stories
with regard to what people's houses look
like
particularly if they're celebrities and
if they're political celebrities so this
is just a lie
they're suppressing the story because
they don't like the content of the story
this is very this has nothing to do
with the specific methodology of the
story they didn't give out her address
they didn't say go harass her nothing
like that they just printed a story
which is extremely newsworthy that the
marxist founder
of a marxist organization who suggests
that america
is deeply enthralled to white supremacy
just bought a gigantically expensive
house
in a super duper white area of
california that's a story
not only is that a story that's a story
with public interest not only is it a
story of public interest it doesn't
threaten her in any way
it does undercut a lot of her claims if
she's so scared of white people if she
believes that white supremacy
is really an institutional problem that
is that is putting black people in
serious danger why in the hell is she
moving to an area with like three black
people she tripled the black population
of tapanga canyon
simply by moving there with members of
her family
okay but but it undercuts that it
undercuts the idea that she's an actual
marxist she's not
or maybe she is she's just like stalin
was a marxist right and stalin also had
a nice dasha
everybody else was living in abject
poverty or being slaughtered in ukraine
but he was living in a really really
nice area
turns out this is the way marxists often
work they get to live in the really nice
house you're the one who has to suffer
nicholas maduro has a really really nice
house
in venezuela so i guess she's just
taking a page from the normal sort of
marxist playbook which is those at the
top of the echelon
they get to have the really nice houses
everybody else has to be a marxist
in any case patrice cullers went on air
with mark lamont hill to try and explain
why she'd been investing you know five
million dollars apparently over the
course of the last year and a half
in real estate pretty non-marxist stuff
there
the the way that i live my life is a
direct support to black people including
my black family members
uh first and foremost and for so many
black folks who are able to invest
in themselves and their community they
choose to invest in their family
and that's what i've chosen to do i have
a child i have a brother
that has severe mental illness that i
take care of
i support my mother and i support many
other family members of mine and so
i see um uh my money as not
my own i see it as um my family's
money as well oh my god okay so so she's
just a capitalist
she's just a capitalist and not only is
she a capitalist she doesn't believe
that america is a deeply white
supremacist place where white people are
routinely targeting black people
because if she did she wouldn't be
moving out to the out to the boonie
she's moving into
i mean that's topanga canyon is like a
very rich area of l.a
i lived in la for 30 years topanga
canyon is not an impoverished area of
l.a it's not a heavily minority area of
la
i love that it's okay for her to use
millions of
millions of dollars that were taken in
via black lives matter
to supposedly fight the systems of white
supremacy and she proceeded to spill
that money into all the systems of white
supremacy
why in order to protect her found weird
because you know what i have the same
exact view about my money my money is
not just my money it is my family's
money it is not your money patrice
colors it is not the money of black
lives matter it is not the money of the
federal government
it is my money and it is my money and my
family's money and i earn money so that
i can help my family i have exactly the
same view that she does about helping my
family which is why i moved to a safer
area
it's why i moved to a better area and
every single american should have the
same exact right and viewpoint about
their money and their family's money as
patrice colors
it just demonstrates what a damned
hypocrite she is she and her
organization go around
talking about how evil america's systems
of capitalism are tear down the family
weird because here you are
talking about how you are the support
system for your family but i thought
that the family was a patriarchal
terrible structure
which was on the blm website until five
seconds ago i was told
that marxism was the solution to the
problem but here you are talking about
your money and your family's money i
noticed you didn't say the people's
money
i noticed you didn't say that patrice's
colors but don't worry it's an
embarrassing story and the media will
step
in to protect patrice colors the the
social media bosses will step in to
protect
patrice i notice they have no sort of
compunction about printing
stories regarding a wide variety of
housing situations for a wide variety of
politicians
but if you step on plm's toes this thing
gets shut down
your establishment media your social
media bosses that they are corrupt and
by the way if you're if you believe that
this is all about suppressing
misinformation again there's a
difference between disinformation and
misinformation
social media bosses should not be in the
process should not be
involved in suppressing quote-unquote
misinformation because sometimes what
they perceive to be misinformation is
actually correct
disinformation is active propaganda on
behalf of a foreign power
you'll notice that over the past few
years there's been a subtle shift from
disinformation to misinformation in the
way that the media talk
about information spread online they
went from disinformation is bad
true because it is foreign propaganda so
misinformation is bad which is anything
we don't like is misinformation and we
will shut it down but i've noticed that
only certain types of misinformation are
being shut down
by the social media bros how's this for
a title
ben shapiro show subscriber destroys
like button with clicks and logic
i'd watch that make it happen gang